It took me a long time to realize this but my emotions aren't always that clear for people to see
As an introvert, I have one hell of a poker face
It's been like that ever since I was a kid
This has its advantages
But it's also pretty tough to deal with the times of course the people who really have a tough for the people around me
Why because they have no idea what I'm feeling at any given time?
This situation was always worse when I was pissed off
I couldn't understand for the life of me
why no one could see how frustrated I was
They would come up to me and talk to me when I quite obviously did not want to be talked to
Why the hell were they doing this were they just trying to mess with me?
Did they enjoy making me more and more furious until I went completely nuts
It took me a while to realize the truth
They had no idea. I was mad in the first place
They just didn't see the signs to me these signs would have been super obvious for anyone to see but I guess
For most people they go unnoticed
Anyway, one sign that people would always miss was the fact that I was responding with one word
When someone would ask me how I was doing I would say
fine
Obviously, I was not fine
But for some reason they didn't understand that and they could see that I was giving them a one-word answer
so they would go away
I quickly learned that the best way to deal with someone who would piss me off was to pretend that everything was okay?
My logic was that if they thought I was happy they would leave me alone, and I wouldn't have to explain to them
Why I was pissed
That was just a conversation
I did not want to have the more I had to talk the more pissed
I would get giving a fake smile and walking away, and did my interaction with them right away
Of course that didn't always work. You can only pretend everything is okay for a while
If someone keeps doing something to piss you off, and you keep giving them a fake smile eventually all that
balls left inside of you is going to Explode
learned that the hard way and
Then of course people get all confused as to why I just blew up over the smallest thing
They really should have understood. I was pissed off at them when I refused to help the weirdest times
oh, what's that you have the answers to tomorrow's math test yep?
I don't need'em you want to perform CPR on me to stop me from dying
nope
Don't touch me I pretty much wanted nothing to do with the people that had pissed me off even if they had something
I really needed I wanted no interaction with them whatsoever. No matter what?
When I was seriously pissed off
I would just shut down emotionally I pretty much answered every question with whatever on the outside
It looked like I was just tired or bored, but on the inside there was a furious rage building up inside of me
I don't know why I expected them to see through this wall of apathy
But I did if the people that pissed me off became truly unbearable
I would just bury myself in a book I would suddenly become very interested in whatever
I was reading just so I didn't have to talk to them it worked, but they still had no idea
I was pissed off at them
They probably knew something was wrong when I was being more social with their cat than I was with them I
Would give all my attention to their pet and completely ignore them I
Still get pissed off of evil, but I've learned to express my emotions
well most of the time anyway and
Most of the time I've learned that the best thing to do when you're pissed off is to get some alone Time I
Cool down ponder how I'm going to kill someone
Realize I don't actually hate them that much and then eventually eventually I realize that I should probably just forgive them
most of the time that is.
This video was based on an article that is posted on our main site if you want to learn more about the subject
[check] the description below and as always don't forget to like and subscribe